so today we are discussing the edges of
the universe because as it turns out
there's more to this question of you
know than just like how much the
universe has expanded since the big bang
because you can also ask the question of
if we were to leave earth tomorrow and
travel at light speed how far could we
ever reach how big of a universe could
we ever interact with and in this
conversation i chat to toby ord who is a
philosopher at the university of oxford
who is trying to answer these really big
picture questions and if you ask these
questions you start to get a glimpse of
just how huge humanity's potential can
be just how giant our cosmic endowment
we've kind of been given is
and of course on the flip side
how much we could waste if we were to go
extinct which of course there is a real
probability of this century and that's a
topic that we also touch on in this
conversation so yeah
kind of high stake stuff um but it's one
of the most fascinating things
fascinating conversations i've ever had
and i'm really excited to share it with
you all
so
you wrote this paper uh recently oh you
recently published it called the edges
of the universe
and honestly it blew my mind a bit
because i always just thought of the
universe kind of i mean i know it's
expanding but i assumed there was only
really one way to describe the the size
of it
um but it turns out that there's many
different ways you've got the observable
universe and then you've got the
affectable universe
and then you've got this
the the eventually observable universe
and then something called the ultimately
observable universe which it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger um so perhaps
starting with the the one that most
people will be familiar with the
observable universe um what is that and
how do you go about calculating the size
of it yeah so that's the the furthest
distance that we can see um so it's kind
of you know everything we can see from
here and there's some slight wrinkles to
this because um uh in the very first
period of the universe uh photons
couldn't travel very far the universe
was opaque um so it actually is a little
bit further than what we can see with
light it includes things that that we
could see with uh you know gravity waves
and things like that um but basically
it's everything that we can see but um
and it's the it's the kind of the
distance that uh that light can have
traveled um from the big bang until now
um
uh so
uh that is not equal to the age of the
universe though that's the first kind of
challenge in these things the universe
is about 13.8 billion years old
but the observable universe
is about 46 billion light years in
radius
so it's about three times
further away than you'd think um
there is the limit of what we can see
and the reason for that is to do with
this expansion of space
most of these issues come from expansion
of space um so uh as the light has you
know started let's say over here at the
point of the big bang and starts
traveling towards us and uh and this is
supposed the furthest distance to which
the light could eventually reach us by
our present moment
uh the space between those points has
expanded during the meantime
uh and so the point um you know that we
can just now see uh has actually gone
you know three times further away is
roughly how it worked in fact it's it's
even slightly worse than that because at
the very moment when it's uh emitted
that photon at the time of the big bang
the universe was extremely small and the
point was actually very close to us
uh
and uh the photon that it emitted
actually started getting further away
from us and then kind of
eventually made its way across uh and
and reached us
so there's some pretty complicated
things going on there uh but basically
it's uh the observable universe is the
the distance at which uh we can see
things uh and so it's of special
interest to astronomers um because they
look out with their telescopes
and they uh you know they see what they
can see
um but that's not that's not the only
kind of region you could be interested
in
right so
that's so the observable is is kind of
what
yeah this describes what we will
ever be all the information we could
ever possibly learn
about well not not quite um uh because
it's it's what we can currently see um
and so uh so what i try to get across in
this paper is that there's a whole lot
of different regions around us different
spheres of different radiuses uh that
uh that in in conversation people just
say the observable universe for all of
them they're not really aware that
they're different to each other
and so the observ observable universe is
everything that we can currently see
but next year
the observable universe will be bigger
it'll be about one light year bigger in
radius
and new galaxies will be visible um
there's there's about uh uh 400 billion
galaxies in the observable universe
but there'll be about 25 more uh each
year
[Music]
as as we can see further and it's
logical that as time goes on you know we
can see further and further away
um but to do with the the the rate of
expansion is accelerating um and it's
accelerating towards an exponential
expansion
uh and
what that means is that uh as it happens
the the the um the number of galaxies
that we'll ever be able to see um
eventually asymptotes towards a number
around about a trillion
and
uh after that point uh space is
expanding so quickly that light from
galaxies that are more distant than that
than the closest trillion um
will actually never be able to make it
you know it is kind of like slowly kind
of moving through space towards us but
this space in between is expanding so
quickly uh that uh uh it never actually
make it here um so there is a kind of
upper limit uh to how far we'd ever be
able to see and that's the uh the
eventually observable universe um and
what's that in in light is uh in in
light years it's about uh 63 billion
light years um so it's not that many
more um we know we can already see 46
billion light years away and we'll be
able to see a bit further away
um as as time goes on and so that's also
of some interest to an astronomer
generally astronomers are interested in
what we can see now not what we'll be
able to see in hundreds of billions of
years from now
but uh you know it's still the same kind
of project right you know people with
telescopes looking out and uh and seeing
things uh and
uh yeah we'll be able to see a lot
further away uh and i should i should
add at this point another kind of
complication on all of this is that you
might think well hang on a second the
universe is is expanding shouldn't we be
able to see further and further and
further away in fact even the things
that are currently 46 billion light
years away that we can see
won't they end up further and further
away such that you know if we can still
see them then now we'll be able to see
hundreds of billions or trillions of
light years away
and that's kind of true um and so
what we can talk about there is
in kind of proper distance
um or proper coordinates uh they are
getting further and further away and you
know they'll approach infinitely far
away as time goes on what do you can you
explain what you mean by proper
coordination yeah it's probably just
what you normally think of in terms of
space um if there if if space expands by
a factor of two then their distance in
this measurement will go up by a factor
of two
um but there's another special way of
doing it which is called co-moving
coordinates and these are the weird ones
but they're the ones that i'm reporting
all my numbers in and so uh
and co-moving coordinates are where you
factor out the expansion of space
uh so if spaces has expanded by a factor
of two we just um uh and we're still
talking about the same galaxy um we say
it's the same distance away
um so it's kind of like how far away
would it be if we were using
measurements as they are today
um even though we're talking about what
we'll be able to see in the future and
it's relevant you're using like a frame
of reference
like a grid that is based upon the
actual physical objects within exactly
opposed to the this like point in space
exactly as a way of measuring distance
um and and so it turns out to be very
convenient and about you know half or
more of the stuff you want to do in
cosmology on these kinds of distance
scales you want to use these these
special co-moving coordinates um and
uh yeah otherwise everything just keeps
getting further and further away but you
find that when what you're interested in
is something like well what kind of like
proportion further out we'll be able to
see or something like that and the
answer you know as i say is the is the
difference between 63 billion and 46
billion so it's we'll be able to see
about 50 further than we can see now in
terms of the galaxies themselves
um
and uh
yeah so uh
uh whereas it'll actually be some
ridiculous number of light years you
know uh you know quintillions of light
years or whatever at different times and
you know crazy numbers um but those
numbers just represent huge gulfs of
emptiness um and they're just not that
relevant so so what we generally do is
we we factor all of that out and we talk
about like in in kind of today's terms
it's like an inflation adjustment
actually um uh maybe it may be a literal
kind of inflation adjustment um
where we're just uh you know we're
saying in today's dollars what would
that be rather than saying you know your
children will be trillionaires and it's
like well but will it will a trillion
dollars buy anything it's like no
actually they'll be living below the
poverty line or something like okay well
what's that in today's money
so
wouldn't so you know we're talking about
these insane distances in these these
galaxies right on the very
the very edge of what we you know we can
see
um
aren't these things going to get
redshifted to oblivion
i i presumably because one of the things
you mentioned in your paper is that um
because
you know we're dealing with photons that
are like
doing you know they're doing their very
best to reach us but like they're really
dealing with this expansion of space um
wouldn't it appear that some of the
the galaxy's right on the very edge of
of what we can see will almost like stop
in time like kind of like an object
falling into a black hole
yeah so there's a couple of things going
on there so one of them is that there's
um is that space is expanding so uh so
one the basically the key to all of this
if you want to do the maths of it and
actually compute these numbers and
things is something called the scale
factor
which is just written as a
and the scale factor at any time uh
represents how much things have grown
and shrunk um and what we normally do is
we say that the scale factor today is
one um it's like today's units it's kind
of like we're saying we're adjusting for
inflation it's it's like it's actually
exactly the inflation adjuster you know
if you're doing this with currency
um and we set it at one for today
because we want to know it in today's
today's units um and in the very early
universe uh this scale factor was
extremely small um
uh and things were much closer together
um and so
uh what happened is that if if a um if
one of these galaxies that we can only
just see now like at the very edge of
our distance emitted a photon towards us
um then that photon its wavelength um
you know came out at a certain kind of
pattern but then that pattern has been
expanded by the scale factor
uh and the photon has lost a lot of
energy in that process it's a kind of
strange process where it can
mysteriously lose energy and the energy
doesn't really go anywhere
as its energy is to do with its
wavelength as wavelength gets stretched
right it's being spread out throughout
space i guess yeah so over each unit
kind of area yeah it's it is weird you'd
think that that it would be
there'd be like each each bit of it
would have less energy but there'd be
more of it or something so by the time
you absorb the whole thing you get the
energy back but actually
uh it doesn't quite work like that it's
something i don't fully understand but
it's uh these things just have low
energy um there's there's some other
mysteries like this to do with expansion
of space that that the conservation of
energy doesn't actually hold in the
universe that has this kind of expansion
of space um it's not clear that you can
exploit that in some manner to get the
free energy out but the standard
conservation of energy principles need
to get modified uh it's it's pretty
weird um but anyway these things are
expanding and as they expand they move
towards redder kind of colors
and so that's one thing you can see is
that uh
um
is uh yeah and that's i think probably
the best way to think about it rather
than as a doppler shift like that it's
moving away from you um like a you know
a car you know going down the road
um sounding like lower pitched um but
rather just to think that it emits this
photon and the photon doesn't care about
what speed the thing it was on was
travelling because it still travels at
the speed of light relative to you but
rather the expansion of spaces has
stretched this photon
um and so that that causes a redshift
um but there's there's also another kind
of and that's why the things will they
will get redder and redder you know
these things are the very limit of our
vision
um but there there's also a kind of
temporal based version of this which you
kind of need a diagram to really
understand but uh um if you if you take
something uh let's see
something that's quite far away from us
say um
uh
let's say 10 billion light years away
from us or something
we can see that
well actually let's say something 20
billion light years away
um you know we can currently see things
at that distance with the hubble
telescope for example i can we can see
galaxies at that distance but we see
them as they were in the past right we
see them as they were um
uh many billions of like many billions
of years ago um not quite 10 billion
because of this expansion thing um but
uh the
um so we see them as they were in the
past and you could ask a question will
we ever see it uh as it is right now um
and the answer for something that's
that's uh 20 billion light years away is
no um we will actually never get to see
what's happening there at this instant
so what's happening there 13.8 billion
years after the big bang at that you
know that time
and uh yeah we will never see that um
uh
and you might say well then what what do
we see like if we just watch it we
record a video of that
of that um
uh that galaxy that's 20 billion light
years away and we keep that video going
you know over billions of years with our
telescope set up uh and uh you know
maybe like we watch this video you know
what on earth happens like how can we
not see it ever catch up and the answer
is that the video kind of slows down
like if we had like high accuracy and we
could see individuals walking around on
those planets um let's say
we would see them getting slower and
slower um
and uh this is a kind of um
uh i think this is called cosmological
time dilation um it's it's it's not that
they're actually going slower or
something it's just to do with it that
um uh
the way that the photons are kind of
coming to us um
uh
sort of fewer and fewer are reaching us
right like the the frequency with which
they would they would be reaching us is
is reducing
yeah exactly you could think of it yeah
like a frame rate right yes um so uh you
know every time the photons are kind of
you know photon comes off it's a little
bit like a frame or a little a pixel
from a frame uh and then um
yeah exactly and then those are just
kind of taking longer and longer to
reach us um so it's like a degrading
video connection or something uh you
know like a uh you're watching some
streaming service and the frames that
it's giving you are slowing down slowing
down slowing down and there's some
certain point in the movie that you're
never going to be able to see beyond but
it doesn't mean that the movie actually
didn't didn't happen um just that we
don't see it
and that's good so that's called the
that moment from which you you you cease
to
keep receiving information from that
distant galaxy it's called the
cosmological event horizon correct yeah
um yeah and so this is how this this
usually comes up in astronomy um or
cosmology um kind of from this strange
direction of saying
um
you know
how far away would you have to go
such that you can never see what's
happening now at that point you know so
so it's a somewhat kind of tortured way
of of
and the fact that we're having trouble
kind of comprehending this is is a real
phenomenon um
uh so let's just pause that that thread
and then ask this other question and
then we'll see how they can align up
right so
a much more natural question and a kind
of the kind of question you know we've
currently dealt with two of these
different different edges of the
universe um one of them is
uh the observable universe what we can
currently see
and the other one is the eventually
observable universe how far we'll ever
be able to see
so
but there's another one which is the
affectable universe how far could we
ever actually affect um and that's puts
the limit on how far we could travel and
so on
um
if we could travel at the speed of light
then we could reach the entire
affectable universe
so
uh and we can actually we can affect
this whole universe um if you you know
shine a torch uh up into the sky um uh
then photons released from that torch uh
will leave our galaxy and uh you know
our galaxy is not so
uh there is some dust floating around
and things but there's not so much that
that will block all the photons um and
there's not so many stars the stars are
relatively sparse
and so uh you know photons will indeed
travel uh the entire uh distance that
they're they're allowed to travel um and
i guess if that torch was pointed in the
right direction at least to hit one of
these uh these galaxies then there would
actually be some you know some influence
that you'd be having on things at some
extraordinary distance
and as time goes on you know these
photons that you release from the torch
go further and further
and
in fact if we're using the kind of not
inflation-adjusted
you know coordinates just the regular
proper coordinates uh then that that
photon will go on forever right it'll
get further and further away and in fact
it will go acceleratingly far away
because the the space between it and us
keeps expanding faster and faster
so eventually you know it will reach you
know any ridiculous distance that you
care to name from us
uh but the galaxies will also be moving
away faster and faster and so if you
want to ask this question about well how
far could it go according to kind of
current
units of
you know the kind of grid of galaxies
um and the answer is that it could go
about 16 and a half billion light years
from from the earth
so it could hit a galaxy that is
currently 16 and a half billion light
years away from the earth that's another
way to say it
uh and
that is but it couldn't hit one that's
17 billion at least according to our
current measurements
so
um
uh and this there is a sphere therefore
about 16 and a half billion light years
um across which is about a third of uh
the the observable universe's radius um
so substantially smaller and in terms of
volume
uh it's because it's about a third the
radius you know it's about a 27th of the
volume or something like that
uh wouldn't it be
wouldn't the sphere be 16.5 billion it
would actually be twice that no because
the radius is 16.5
so the diameter would be would be two
diameters yeah yes okay okay uh that's
right um i'll do it all in radius so we
don't have to worry about uh doubling
everything and then halving
um and uh yeah so
uh so that's the furthest that we can
affect um and if we're trying to you
know if we if we have our sights set up
on the heavens and we think um you know
what are the limits for humanity uh how
many galaxies might we ever travel to um
or uh or settle or you know utilize
their resources for something or make
some amazing art projects you know
through through space or uh or bring
life to them all and kind of let them
kind of you know evolve in their their
own work independent kind of worlds or
whatever it is that we want to do um
what's the kind of upper bound on what
we might be able to achieve
then it's all to do with this effectable
universe it's not to do with the
observable universe at all that's just
the stuff we can see but we know that we
at least according to the current
understanding of this physics that we'll
never be able to reach most of that
space so it's not the relevant thing the
relevant thing is the this affectable
universe
it's it's funny that you mention
sort of because
the observable universe is the thing we
always hear about astronomers always
talk about it but that's actually a very
passive thing right that's it's about oh
information that we can receive but
arguably it's more it's it's it to me
it's more morally interesting more more
uh
valuable to us to actually think about
the affectable universe because that's
something that we can actually have
influence over right yeah
so there's a few reasons why this has
happened why you don't hear about this
um i mean i agree with you i think it's
the more interesting thing um so one of
them is just a general kind of
past versus future bias right like in in
um at universities they study history
but they don't study the future um
uh and the the the past is is you know
it's happened it's kind of determinate
um uh and also
information about it reaches us
and we can we can learn about it in a
way that's very different to how we
think about the future um but also the
past is settled you know it's not that
we can go and change the past or
something you know barring some time
travel um so
uh so you might think that why do we
need to know about the past it's already
happened and the reason you need to know
about it is because you could learn
things that then relevant to the future
um but you could also ask these
questions about the future and what
would ever be able to achieve and what
are the limits you know and some of that
can be scientifically answered
you know what we'll do with these
resources is a very open question but
trying to understand the limits of them
it's a little bit like trying to
understand the limit of light speed or
something like that it's useful to know
what are the limits you know in this
domain that we're working with
how large a canvas does humanity have uh
you know to potentially paint on for the
rest of its uh existence we don't know
what we would paint and it might be kind
of more futile to speculate about that
but to kind of learn you know how large
is the canvas and you know what are the
colors that we have available and things
like that are the types of things that
are scientifically
uh doable so that's one of the reasons
this is just a kind of past future
reason
another big reason
is uh is yeah well is to do with
astronomers and just that that they have
these telescopes
and they're mainly thinking about we
look out with telescopes and we see
things we sit at the top of this past
light cone of stuff that's all kind of
come up to us
and
we don't send spacecraft out to settle
the distant reaches of space or
something it's not something that we do
in our field uh maybe maybe people will
do that in the future but that sounds a
bit like science fiction to us and
and you know that's perhaps why we got
into astronomy in the first place due to
dreams about these things but now we're
serious kind of academics and we study
the objective stuff that you know that
comes to us
so that's another reason but then a
third kind of reason is that
that
we only
our understanding of cosmology you know
keeps evolving over time
but
and that this current understanding
which is called uh that everything i'm
i'm saying today is based on a thing
called lambda cdm
um which is the it's also called the
concordance cosmology it's kind of the
most agreed simple model of the
the universe that kind of fits almost
all the data that we have
um and then there are various extensions
to it which are more speculative that
people have and some of those extensions
mean that some of the things i'm saying
would not be true if you know if they
these extensions turned out to be
correct
uh and the lambda stands for the
cosmological constant that einstein
invented
um
and uh cdm stands for cold dark matter
where the idea is that the dark matter
is something which is cold which
cosmologists or astronomers cold means
it's not going near the speed of light
that's a weird weird use of the word
cold but uh there you go um if it was
going near the speed of light uh then
the math turns out a bit differently so
it means that the dark matter is is low
energy dark matter exactly so low energy
dark matter and that there's also dark
energy in this form of this cosmological
constant not some other form
and so that's lambda cdm
uh that's the basis of all of this on
that model you get a finite affectable
universe uh but when people were first
exploring these questions uh people like
uh like freeman dyson has a has a
fabulous paper in 1979 that was one of
the earliest papers really exploring
this kind of what could ever be achieved
over a distant time
they didn't know about this accelerating
expansion
so they thought that the type of
expansion of the universe was uh was if
anything's slowing down um and if if the
expansion was slowing down or if it was
constant
uh then you can eventually get anywhere
um
uh and uh eventually you do catch up
with the expansion that's happening
between you and the next galaxy and you
can always make it to the to the next
galaxy further on
uh and so on that view there is a finite
observable universe at the moment
but eventually you'll be able to observe
arbitrarily far because the light can
make it all the way to you
and eventually you can travel
arbitrarily far
so on that view the observable universe
or the currently observable universe is
an important distance but there is no
eventually observable universe it's
infinite and there is no affectable
universe
it's uh it's infinite
uh so you don't you don't get these
other spears
but so it was only uh it's only about 20
years ago that we realized that there
was this accelerating expansion and
things changed and effectively
the kind of
you know the concepts or the wikipedia
pages and so on have not caught up with
this um that their current view is that
uh is that you have this finite kind of
region that's affectable and then a
whole lot of things follow from this
um so you've described so far the
observable universe the affectable
universe you've mentioned the eventually
observable universe which is oddly
enough the the if you add up the two the
two uh distances the two radiuses of the
observable and the affectable you come
to the eventually observable universe
because that's the
maximum possible distance um in in
co-moving coordinates that a photon
emitted at the moment of the big bang
can ever possibly travel
that's right in terms of the further the
furthest other point of something of a
galaxy moving through space that that
initial photon could ever reach
but there's something bigger than that
right that's right so so let's just
before we get to it let's let's just
kind of like you've done a nice summary
there i'll just kind of add to your
summary to just kind of like cement what
we know so the if you think in terms of
light cones uh which which hopefully
many many people are familiar with
um you know in in classic flat space
time minkowski space time you've just
got a a cone above you like in the
future direction which is expanding
which corresponds to
all of the places you could ever get to
from here and when you could get there
and you've got an expanding pass like
cone as well which is all of the points
in space that could ever have influenced
you and things that are in neither
neither the future light code nor the
past like code are things that are
causally separate from you they're
events that uh
um that neither can influence the other
um they roughly correspond to what we
thought of a simultaneous before we
before we knew about special relativity
um and so
that picture has changed now and if we
do this stuff in uh in the uh if we do
it in regular coordinates uh where we we
don't adjust for the the expansion of
space then things started off very close
to each other at the big bang then they
started getting further away um so if
our past light cone this is well let's
look at it from from now so this is now
and humanity at this moment if we look
at our past light cone it looks like
it's spreading out
but because the we knew at the start of
the
start of time things were very close
together it actually
you know connects back together things
were very close again it's kind of like
an at the bottom of an hourglass
shape or an onion shape
um and and the future light cone starts
going kind of up like this but
eventually it
it you know it it starts uh expanding
really fast um
and this kind of exponential shape to it
um
so it's it's a pretty confusing looking
thing and it's not that useful for
calculating anything
so let's do it all again in these
co-moving coordinates where we've kind
of adjusted for for the expansion
in that case the past light cone
looks kind of like this
and the the base of the pass light cone
is the uh is the observable universe
it's the the furthest back in time kind
of things that we can see
um what does the top of it look like
well it doesn't keep expanding out like
that or otherwise we would be able to
kind of go anywhere
at arbitrarily far distance because we
can only go um uh you know this
affectable universe
the top of it ends up asymptoting um to
a particular distance away from uh from
the center which is the 16.5 billion
light years and the affectable universe
is like the top of the future light cone
and the observable universe is the
bottom of the past light cone
and eventually if we just stay here
forever and don't do anything don't go
anywhere we just stay on earth for like
very long periods of time
we'll be time will be will we really
fire up this diagram and we'll have this
massive observable universe that we'll
be kind of looking down on and that's
the eventually observable universe so
you can kind of tie all of those things
together on these diagrams
then
i said there's this other one
and the other one is maybe slightly less
fundamental than these but here's a kind
of question that comes up if you think
about philosophy of science
a lot of people wonder what's beyond the
observable universe how could you ever
know like you know uh you know could
there be like a giant floating teapot
you know just outside the observable
universe that we'd never know about uh
how could you say that there couldn't be
or that they wouldn't be you know is it
unfalsifiable like if we talk about
there being pink elephants you know
beyond the observable universe or what
have you
uh and it's meant to be a kind of
challenge to
uh you know falsifiability or
observability constraints on science
because uh you know it's kind of saying
well there's some kind of region
where we could actually test things and
beyond that um we couldn't um
and now i think that there are things
you could say about that you know make
sensible predictions about what will
happen out there for example it's not
that unreasonable to think it'll be
pretty much like what happens inside it
will just kind of continue on in some
kind of fairly homogeneous manner um
but you can see that there's at least
some distance that where there's some
interesting question that you can start
to ask about philosophy of science
because you could net it's fundamentally
impossible to ever know or you know
find out about it
well that we've already seen that that
distance doesn't correspond to the
observable universe because if we just
wait a year um you know we can see a bit
further um
and so you kind of wait longer and
eventually you know we'll find out about
that region that we were wondering
whether it had pink elephants in it or
not
um so that can't be the right one
uh and you might say well the okay the
eventually observable universe is the
furthest we could ever know about um and
that's true if we're stuck on earth
uh but if we um if we just move
you know uh a light year in some
direction suppose we we send a
spacecraft to our nearest star
proxima centauri and then
it brings with it a telescope and it
looks out from there
well it's about four light years away
from here and it will be able to see
about four light years further in the
direction that it went
um
and so
uh it will be able to see you know new
parts of uh
of the observable universe
and you could say well what's you know
what's the limit to that and the limit
the limit to this process is if we send
something out
at very close to the speed of light
and it gets to the very edge of the
affectable universe
and then from there it looks out
how far will it be able to see and the
answer is the radius of the affectable
universe plus the radius of the
eventually observable universe so it
will basically reach some other planet
and it will see the eventually
observable universe centered on that
planet
and so it won't be able to see more than
we can see it'll just see a different
it's like it's the spotlight will be
shining on a different part of this kind
of wider universe
you use a nice analogy of being like on
top of a different mountain yeah yeah
we're on top of the mount the mountain
located in in ours you know where we
are centrally located then you can climb
and go to the top of another mountain
and see further but the issue is of
course that you can't necessarily
as a single observer you won't be able
to see all of these different things
because you are then
you've got the whole problem that you
can't move faster than the speed of
light that's right so and you won't be
able to communicate it back to earth um
and and this i guess brings us to a kind
of particularly poignant aspect about
these things
just as the observable universe every
year grows right it's kind of nice you
know you can see further and further and
further and maybe there's some upper
limit to how far you can see but at
least it's nice that things are getting
bigger and more expansive and maybe it
turns out that you know people are
slowing down or whatever it like the
galaxies you see you don't see their
entire
like temporal extent you only see the
first part of it and so the frame rate
starts to drop and so on on these other
galaxies you're looking at
and they also end up getting kind of
red-shifted and and dimmer for various
reasons you know basically because
there's fewer and fewer frames being
sent to you which corresponds to getting
dimmer
um
okay um but okay so that's a little bit
depressing in some ways but it's also
somewhat you know expansive uh but the
affectable universe is shrinking uh at
the same kind of rate in terms of light
years per year it's at the moment
because of how we've normalized
everything it's shrinking by one light
year per year
um and the other one's growing by one
light year per year uh so if we if we
wait and we just fritter away our time
on earth um the affectable universe gets
smaller and smaller and there are
galaxies that are slipping kind of
beyond our reach uh every year
uh yeah every year yeah yeah right yeah
three galaxies per year uh slip beyond
our reach uh so
the more we delay
uh the the smaller the um the canvas uh
that we have to to paint on
uh so
yeah um is this
is this because to me that seems like uh
an enormous tragedy like literally a
tragedy of astronomical scale because
um
i mean i personally believe that we're
quite likely to be the only um
advanced civilization within our
observable universe and so i'm a big fan
of spreading consciousness i think
consciousness overall is a good thing
and we should have more of it and
you know what what this is suggesting is
that every
every moment that we wait we're losing
stuff
with which you know matter and energy
with which we can use to make more
consciousness
so it creates a kind of urgency a moral
imperative to to get a move on and start
spreading through space yeah i mean
that's right it's it's it's huge i mean
it an entire galaxy uh
uh every uh every year i mean over three
galaxies so it's it's uh
it's almost kind of beyond the ability
to to comprehend um now i should say
that not all galaxies are created equal
and
we we live in a fairly large galaxy uh
there are ones that are bigger but i
think i don't know what the fraction is
but something like 90 or more are
smaller and so some of these galaxies
you know might be some very tiny ones
and so forth um but you know that's
that's a rather unusual like approach to
kind of like
three galaxies per year leaving our
outreach and it's like well they're
small galaxies well
some of them are small but you know
occasionally you lose a big one as well
um and uh and even the small galaxies
are pretty big by by regular standards
um and i guess i could say just a tiny
bit here about the the physical
structure of all of this we've been
talking basically everything i talk
about in in the paper and that we've
talked about here
the units are basically billions of
light years and billions of years um
nothing really happens on a time scale
smaller than a billion years or a
billion light years um when i've kind of
you know worked on this with other
colleagues yeah we often just use units
of
uh yeah gigalite year giga years and so
on um
uh and at that scale space like the the
matter in space is relatively
homogeneous um
uh so the
you know you're familiar i'm sure
everyone's familiar with uh with solar
systems um or planetary systems as
they're called if they're not centered
around the the sun in particular uh and
then also galaxies um where you've got a
whole lot of um a whole lot of stars
orbiting the center of a galaxy
uh but beyond that um you've got groups
of galaxies or clusters of galaxies um
basically it's a bit confusing but
clusters turns out to just be the name
of a big group of galaxies they're not
really a separate scale
and the
our galaxy uh the milky way is part of
about 50 to 50 to 100 galaxies
called the local group and it's the
second biggest uh andromeda is the
biggest
uh and so that's that's that's the local
group um and these are gravitationally
bound uh that means that that the space
between them is not really expanding um
that effectively the gravity is strong
enough to pull them in uh in a way that
overwhelms the expansion of space so the
distances don't blow up to infinity as
time time goes on and that means that
we'll we'll always be able to access the
the local group which i think the
current count is 55 for these galaxies
so
there's 55 galaxies that we'll always be
able to reach no matter how slow we are
but the others are the all the other
groups and clusters will be separated
and eventually each each of these groups
or clusters is separated from each other
one um
and uh and so the observable universe
sorry the affectable universe eventually
shrinks down to basically just your own
your own group unless you can have you
know spread out such that you've reached
many other groups and clusters there are
different things you could do yeah there
are different things you could do you
could attempt to actually bring them
back to a local place in order to kind
of um let's say paint you know a
a painting that has a whole lot of
internal coherence and involves kind of
you know like or perhaps more plausibly
maybe you want to build some giant
computer structure or some kind of
society that involves lots of
interconnections and causal
interconnectedness
in that case you could exceed you know
what you could do with a single uh
single cluster by by bringing more
matter together
um you could you could in theory go all
the way out to halfway to the edge of
the affectable universe um that's the
distance that's the point of no return
distance that you could ever get back to
the earth from and then start bringing
the stuff in between back to earth
um or you could just do a kind of
you know maybe it doesn't all need to be
causally connected um it can you can
have different projects that go on in
every different cluster maybe they're
all kind of coordinated in some way
you're all painting pieces of a kind of
great
painting that will never be assembled in
one place but is somehow all coherent
or you could uh
you could just let them do whatever they
want um because ultimately after a while
they'll never be able to affect each
other again
uh and so you could have a kind of
libertarian future where each group gets
to kind of choose what it wants to do
and doesn't actually have to be part of
a unified whole
so
tell me why it is that you are working
on these sorts of questions because i
can imagine a lot of people find them
you know it's fascinating but like this
seems a little bit abstract and you know
you're a researcher at the future future
of humanity institute um which focuses a
lot on sort of ethical dilemmas and and
um
reducing existential risks so what's
what's your motivation behind
the work this particular
work so in part it is just curiosity um
this is something where
i'm
you know it's really interesting stuff
basically uh and i i came to it in part
from just trying to understand how does
this past light cone actually work in
this future light code in an expanding
universe with a big bang and so on um
you know is it the case that that past
light cone eventually curved back on
itself and touched touches or something
you know what was going on there and i
just kept trying to find out more and
more about it
um
but yeah i'm i'm interested in it
because i'm interested in humanity's
potential
so
in general we know of very few uh limits
on what we might ever be able to achieve
so
one such potential limit comes from the
habitability of the earth
the current guesses on this uh that
in somewhere between about 500 million
years and one and a half billion years
the earth due to the sun's
uh warming and expansion
the earth will warm uh sufficiently that
it'll be very difficult for complex life
to continue to exist
uh and this is sometimes put as an upper
bound on what we'll be able to achieve
but uh
that you know it
the sun doesn't get warmer very quickly
um and then of course
you know we're we're planning you know
currently the breakthrough star shot and
things you know there are missions
planned to go to other stars you know
leaving in the next few decades uh so
the idea that somehow billions of years
have elapsed and we're still stuck on
earth and we're we're struggling with
the temperature getting too hot is a bit
of a weird kind of limit
yeah seems implausible so then you start
to ask about well you know what are the
duration limits like how long will there
be stars shining for uh and the answer
to that is that there'll be naturally
burning stars um uh going for
something in the order of 10 trillion
years
the the new stars will still be being
created up until about 10 trillion years
and some of the longest burning very dim
stars though um last for about 10
trillion years
so you know 10 20 trillion years into
the future they'll still be naturally
burning stars but then there's also
going to be this kind of strange forms
of star formation where big clumps of
hydrogen gas that were not quite big
enough to burn uh to fuse
where two of them eventually due to
random effects in a galaxy with 100
billion stars eventually two of them
collide and have just enough fuel to
burn for another 10 trillion years
and this kind of process will carry on
for for much longer i think thousands of
times longer
so there will be stars burning in you
know the milky way for um uh for i think
it's quadrillions of years so
very very large you know you need
scientific notation at that point very
long periods of time um but then also
you know how far could we ever affect
you know like how much how many stars
could we reach it's very natural
questions if you're just trying to
understand can we say anything about the
upper bounds to what we might be able to
achieve
and uh
and then you start to get into these
questions about how far could we ever go
is that the observable universe and so
on so i kind of got intellectually
curious about this but also that
curiosity was driven because i take
seriously that we will have a future
and i think that there's a very
realistic chance let's say greater than
5 or 10 or something that that future
will involve um traveling as far as we
can through space uh with some kinds of
projects uh that that
rather than that we find ourselves in
this vast world and that we never
actually explore it we just forever
repeatedly failed to explore it and uh
that that seems possible maybe we'll
make some decision to never explore it
or something and we'll we'll bind that
into some constitutional law so that no
kind of
curious people ever come up and try to
explore it
um
i don't know why we would do that it
seems it seems misguided i mean there
are there seem to be people
on earth alive today who are very anti
the idea of
even the math mission like yes i i find
it mind boggling and i think it's it
speaks for just a lack of imagination on
their heart and
probably some other weird
so so we might personality traits but
yeah
we might have something like that that
um but it seems very plausible to me
that as time goes on you know the and
the the relative costs of doing these
things become cheaper and cheaper
uh that eventually we'll we'll do it uh
in which case
that would be a very big deal like a
very very big thing going on in the
universe um and in fact if we did
explore like that the the largest known
structures in the universe basically the
larger structures i mean cosmologists
just refer to this as the the larger
structures
are at about a scale of um
uh about a billion light years across um
they're cosmic voids um so beyond the
scale of these these groups and and
clusters
they're arranged into these filaments
these very long kind of tendrils of
stuff that's it that's in this what's
called the cosmic web where you can
imagine various kind of brightly shining
points with kind of slightly dimmer
ones of these filaments connecting to
other brightly shining points and each
point has several that come off from it
in a kind of three-dimensional web
and uh
these there's these kind of
one-dimensional filaments there's these
kind of zero-dimensional brightly
shining points that are particularly
dense with galaxies and sometimes those
points are called superclusters
uh and uh although eventually this whole
web will disperse and be stretched apart
by expansion so it this this is current
structure but it won't last forever
and these voids these kind of
three-dimensional regions between them
are the biggest things and uh the
biggest ones of those that have been
discovered are about a billion light
years across so
and there's reason to think that you
can't get bigger than that in terms of
uh to do with like how much time there
has been how much time they'll ever be
and their force of gravity versus the
force of expansion and so on that these
are the largest structures that will
naturally arise
naturally arise where you rule out
intelligent organization as part of
what's natural
and so that's how it's normally thought
of but actually it seems that we could
create structures which are larger than
any other structures in the universe
because the affectable universe is you
know is many times larger than one of
these these regions
uh so it could actually be that that
uh
i mean it would be it would be enough i
think if uh
humanity was special despite the vast
scales of the universe by being some
very fragile and very complex kind of
arrangement of things around the surface
of planets and so on which has this kind
of ability to know the universe as a
whole and to love and to feel and and so
on
but it could also be the case that even
in terms of raw scale um that humanity
uh ends up being uh able to kind of
orchestrate things on the largest uh
larger scales of anything in uh in the
reachable parts of space
i think a common
pushback that many people who are sort
of skeptical of of the importance of us
examining the you know in exploring the
affectable universe is that they have
very
strong beliefs that there are already
alien civilizations out there there is
already consciousness we just haven't
seen it yet um
what would you say to that argument
so i think this this often comes from
just the sheer number of stars um where
people
um i guess there's a couple of reasons
one of them is the sheer number of stars
i think this is not a good argument um
uh it's true that there are a lot of
stars and if you haven't seen a number
like 100 billion before you know you
tend to think it's just so big um
uh
but
there are numbers that are you know
comparatively small um you know there
are probabilities that are less than one
in a hundred billion um
uh you know what 100 billion is uh is 10
to the power of 11. um so if uh if you
roll a 10-sided die 11 times you know
the chance that that you get one every
time is is the same you know is that the
inverse probability of that number of
things
um could it be that in order to create
the first self-replicating uh molecules
you need to do something that is that is
less likely uh than
rolling a ten-sided die um you know say
20 times getting a one of it and getting
a one every time seems entirely
plausible especially as the the smallest
known uh
um structures of dna or rna that are
self-replicating are
quite long much longer than 20 base
pairs or or 100 base pairs
and we don't know
it could be that there are a whole lot
of um
catalysts and things that that help
those first ones get created through
systematic processes where it doesn't
have to be done kind of you know
randomly or something
but we don't know about that it's very
plausible that actually to get to the
first point way where um you get
something self-replicating you need a
combinatorial
thing you know some arrangement of these
base pairs maybe the smallest
arrangement that actually works is
really quite long
um and then that could give you
extremely small probabilities you know
probabilities like you know one in a
google or something like that there's
one in 10 to the power of 100. if
there's if there's what four base pairs
then and suppose you need um
200 of them to have the small in the
right combination to have the smallest
thing then that probability you know is
less than one in a google
uh so
uh there could be some steps like that
uh that are needed in order to get to uh
to be an intelligent
civilization on a planet
and i think the origin of life is the
most plausible one to have extremely low
probability
and so uh yeah i wrote a paper with with
ander sandberg and eric drexler on this
where we consider
our ignorance
uh about this that it's very plausible
that this the probability of getting to
where we are
is extraordinarily low um and it's very
plausible that it's a number that's
correspondingly
it's smaller than the number of stars in
the observable universe is big um and
such that if you multiply them together
like the chance of getting life around
any particular planet by the number of
planets that you indeed find that uh
that you should expect less than one per
per region of this kind of size
and
then when we look out at the the night
sky and we look out with our telescopes
and so on and we don't find any any
evidence of any kind of structure or
life or any observable effects anywhere
uh
uh
rather than treat this as some kind of
paradox it would only be a paradox if we
had some very strong reason to think
that there really should be but if we
start off with the view that oh it's
entirely plausible that we're completely
alone and it's also entirely plausible
that actually it's it's pretty common
and uh and that it happens regularly
around different stars you look up at
the the night sky and you see no
evidence of any life and you think oh i
guess it was i guess it was unlikely
then um is is the response
i think it's partly because people
assume that because we exist it's
therefore statistical proof or very
strong statistical evidence that life is
easy to create but actually if we had
another data point just one other data
point somewhere independent i don't
think mars counts because actually mars
you know if we find like my life on mars
arguably mars and earth were sort of
formed out of the same soup right but
like if we did find evidence of of
life elsewhere outside of our solar
system now all of a sudden the
probability will go up massively but our
mere existence because it's only one
data point it doesn't actually
give you any meaningful information
about the probability is that correct
yeah that's right um and it's it's easy
to
fall into that trap of thinking that it
does but ultimately
you know
once you get intelligent life it will
look around and find itself on a planet
where life started it will always see
that it can't see anything else and if
you have a situation where there's only
one type of evidence that you could see
and there's no other evidence that you
could see then that evidence doesn't
actually count um it you know you can
you can do that more complicatedly with
the probability theory and bayesian
statistics and so on but basically um
yeah if there's only one thing you could
observe
regardless of how an event turns out
then it doesn't tell you anything about
the probability of that event and that's
what's going on here uh in in our paper
we actually have these elaborate
appendices where we where i think anders
has uh calculated out for different
things like finding um you know uh
intelligent life somewhere else on a
different star and or even a different
planet in our solar system and so on
what would this do to this kind of prior
distribution of probabilities of
of life arising and so on and has tried
to kind of pre-calculate what all the
updates would be if you were to get
these pieces of evidence
um so that's that's
if people are interested in that they
can find out more about it um and and i
think it's below i think this is also a
case of the
copernican principle kind of going wrong
and i think that this is something where
you know pre-copernicus the idea was at
least in the west uh that we thought
earth was special and humanity was very
special
um and a kind of teleological view that
it was all created for us with a kind of
purpose and so on that we're at the
center of the universe and so on and so
forth uh and then uh copernicus you know
uh had a had a more successful
scientific model by putting the earth
not at the center of uh the universe but
in particular going around the sun
i guess it's open question where the sun
then had to be at the center of the
universe or not and it didn't um
and i think that scientists have over
updated on this this rule they thought
oh that's very successful to assume that
we're not the be all and end all and in
fact that we're in some very typical or
mediocre position and sometimes called
the principle of mediocrity to assume
that we're basically in a typical
position
and i i think that the correct version
of this is you need to account for
selection effects so as an example this
would predict we're at a typical point
in space which would suggest that most
points in space or like half the points
in space or near the surface of planets
uh but actually almost no points in
space even near the earth are near the
surface of the earth they're either
inside the earth or hopelessly far up in
space
um and then almost all points in space
are nowhere near a planet they're not
even in a galaxy they're in one of these
cosmological voids
and yet we don't find ourselves in a
void we find ourselves in an
extraordinarily special place and we
know that um
and so basically you you need to say
something a modified version not just
that we're mediocre on all attributes
but rather we're in a typical place
among the places we could possibly find
ourselves or something like that
and
and so once you adjust for that this
kind of mediocrity assumption or
component consumption doesn't suggest
that it's typical that life should
evolve around a planet um you know any
old planet it just says that we should
find ourselves in a typical place where
life evolves which which would suggest
for example that it's that a decent
fraction of life that evolves in the
universe evolves on the surface of a
planet because if almost all of it
involved in cosmic voids or something
it's a bit weird that we don't find
ourselves there so you can still get
something out of this principle but not
what these people thought which is that
most worlds would probably be habitable
and inhabited
it's almost like anthropocentrism you
know the idea that we are
in some way special became
because of the the the ways in the
middle ages which were so they were so
anti anyone who would suggest that the
earth wasn't the center of everything um
it became
science became attached to this idea of
that we must be uh of anti-specialism um
and
anti-anti-anthropocentrism but it
actually sounds like there was some
element of truth to that that we
actually yeah quite special yeah that's
right but it's ultimately been you know
um you know
hundreds of years of overreaction you
know it feels like at some point in the
intervening centuries
we should have settled out to the
correct level of um you know of
skepticism of these kind of theories
that were special
but we have not yet achieved that
there's still this kind of reaction um
that you get uh where it's where you
don't want to be confused with the other
side in
galileo versus the the church or
something
instead of saying well there's no
possible chance anyone could confuse me
with the other side of that why don't we
just adopt a more neutral stance on this
and i think it's quite beautiful
actually if that ends up being that
there's an element of truth from the
church side and there's an element of
truth from the from the science side and
and in reality as with all these things
the answer is a bit more complex um
given this that we might be alone uh
might well be the only conscious
consciousness in the universe
you actually wrote a book recently uh
called the precipice which talks about
the likelihood
that we might go extinct in the coming
in the coming century um and the answer
that you came to is is one of the most
terrifying numbers i think i've ever
ever seen uh that we have a one in six
chance so again talking about dice you
know what like rolling a one on a dice
is the probability that we don't just
have a huge catastrophe on earth where
only a few people are alive but
literally
every
every human being possibly every
in form of intelligent life on earth uh
animals included goes extinct um
what the hell
how how can that be the case
yeah no i mean i hope i'm wrong about
this it's one thing to say um so
uh so what i'm looking at in that book
the precipice is existential risk um so
this is the the chance that we have an
existential catastrophe um so this is a
kind of term of art and what it means it
includes extinction the scenario you
talked about but it's a little bit
broader than that and maybe some of my
probability goes into these other
scenarios
because it also includes
um if there was an unrecoverable
collapse of civilization
uh and it also includes uh kind of
dystopian futures um that are
permanently locked in uh so a kind of
world like orwell's 1984
that that was self-supporting and uh you
know had all this apparatus built in
such that this kind of oppressive
totalitarian regime could never be
overthrown
that would count as well and what these
things have in common
is that humanity's kind of once vast
potential
has been reduced to either just one
future the future of just
you know um like where there's no
actions humans can take anymore it's
just the the animals continue perhaps on
the planet surface for a while and then
this the sun gets bigger and they all
die and there's perhaps no more life
anywhere um in the whole universe
so
if so our soaring potential is kind of
reduced to just this kind of one world
that's kind of uh mediocre
uh
or that would also be somewhat true if
there was this collapse of civilization
that we couldn't recover from uh where
uh you know there's still different
futures that are available and we could
do a bit better or a bit worse we could
have better lives or worse lives but a
whole lot of like what could be achieved
over billions of years or trillions of
years and with with galaxies as our
canvas um is all kind of gone
uh and
and then also there's dystopian futures
as well um maybe those futures could
could reach these kinds of cosmological
scales but it might even be a bad thing
if they did um you know it might be that
this this world they've created has very
little value in it perhaps only the the
ruthless uh uh leaders have you know
actually much positive in their lives
and most people are kind of close to
zero or something like that or so very
low complexity yeah there could be all
kinds of lenses you could see it through
where it doesn't sound very good there
are not many lenses you can see it
through really where it does sound any
good at all
whether that's thinking about kind of
the creations in art or science and
knowledge and learning or happiness or
anything it looks pretty bad uh so
uh but what they've got in common yeah
is that that we're trapped we've lost
this vast potential and instead we're
we're trapped in some kind of like
locked in state uh that is bad and will
perpetuate forever and so in all of
these cases uh what we need to do is to
uh is to act now um it's only before we
get locked into the state uh that you
can make any difference um and we can
preserve this potential that we have
so that our children or grandchildren or
distant descendants can fulfill that
potential and and do something really
amazing with it
uh so i look at these different risks
and i i show how humanity's always been
vulnerable to risks of extinction um but
we can use
the the fact that we've uh we've
survived for 200 000 years so far as
some evidence uh 2000 centuries that
we've got through that the background
rate of extinction events is not that
high and we can also use the extinction
rates for other similar animals and so
on and try to build up a better picture
of that
and all of that suggests uh my my best
guess
is that there's about a one in ten
thousand chance per century
that humanity will go extinct from from
natural events
another way to look at that is that on
average we could last about a million
years and that's the typical length of
time a species lasts on earth
but
you know more recently uh particularly
with the development of nuclear weapons
uh humanity's escalating power has
finally reached this point where we can
do such vast effects uh that we could uh
we could destroy ourselves
and we've entered this this time period
that i call the precipice
where
you know we were just talking about the
the affectable universe and kind of all
of these things that we could ever reach
and this kind of potentially vast future
kind of has to go through this this kind
of choke point um and my analogy is is
you know we're on this journey as
humanity and where we've come to this
the only way forward is this narrow path
along cliff side where where a single
misstep uh you could we could fall down
and never be able to recover
uh and that this is the most dangerous
part of our journey so far uh and
uh but it it it can't go on forever um
uh and as i said as you said uh my
estimate ultimately for the the
existential risk this century is about
one in six
uh and i think it's been you know it was
it was smaller last century and if we
don't get our act together it would be
even bigger uh next century uh and so
this is an unsustainable amount of risk
it's not that we could be if we could
survive for a thousand centuries with
risk like this that just the
probabilities don't work out um so
either we will go extinct this century
or one of the next few or in some other
way through a totalitarian regime or
something have our potential kind of
snuffed out
or we will get our act together and work
out how to reduce these risks and
actually take this seriously
uh and that's that's what i hope will
happen
and um
at the moment it's very hard to give
precise estimates to how much we spend
on existential risk um because it's it's
a bit debatable as to what counts does
all spending on climate change count
because climate change is potentially an
existential risk we're probably not all
spending on it because most of that's
not directed at this scenario at all
um but i think we can safely say that we
spend less on
avoiding existential risk than we do on
ice cream uh each year
and i think that that's that's a useful
analogy because a lot of people think
well you know you're saying we should we
should put everything in service of like
survival so that we can do this thing
and to sacrifice the current generation
on the altar of the future and so and i
was like well the least i'm saying
is we should spend more on it than on
ice cream because like that's right
uh so
that yeah that's kind of how i'm
thinking about it that make it an actual
priority um and we can't say that as an
actual priority while it's a lower
priority than ice cream consumption
yeah it seems like people at the moment
are very
it is almost like an addiction to
pessimism in some way and people um
don't
want to entertain these far future
scenarios because they're so you know
understandably there's a lot of bad
stuff happening in the world right now
but
you know there's a
there should be an appropriate amount of
focus on that
compared to the amount of uh
you know the presumed badness if
we do as a species just suddenly
disappear or get permanently curtailed
by some authoritarian regime um
because the amount of value lost there
if you sort of integrated under that
curve over time
is astronomical in comparison to you
know the the sort of current
day issues that are sort of absorbing
most of our funds and resources and
attention to be honest um
so no i'm i'm deeply in agreement um
and
yeah i guess i guess what i liked about
your paper um and generally the work
that also anders who i didn't interview
with um for this channel uh is you you
guys focus on um
sort of the utopian scenarios
um because we we need you know we need
to think about the possible dystopian
scenarios and these existential risks
obviously um sort of acting as sticks
driving us forward
but we also need some carrots to sort of
tantalize us and give us give us some
hope and excitement of like well look
this is also what we you know we this is
the potential that we could achieve
um and that's what i like about your
paper because it's it's it's giving
people this big picture thinking in it
through an optimistic lens which i think
is arguably more constructive
yeah and it's the thing that also drives
all of our work on um on existential
risk
uh is this hope for the future
and it's something where
uh
yeah i think overall um we're pretty
optimistic people uh and it's because we
we think the future um could be so much
better than the present uh that where
you know it would be such a tragedy to
lose it uh and that we you know and also
this realization that
you know that there are high risks at
the moment and that only people of our
time could do something about them means
that we live at this kind of uniquely
high leverage time uh and you know i i
say uh in the book that i think if we do
survive this time um and
and live out you know at least the the
the time span of a typical species uh
say a million years
um
uh or maybe maybe we last as long as the
uh the horseshoe crab um and lasts for
several hundred million years or you
know perhaps even longer but if we last
at any of these time spans um that
people will look back and let's say over
the last million years when when
children are learning about their
history
uh that that our time period uh will be
uh the uniquely important one
uh and so it may be that
maybe uh like how we think about the
middle ages and make all of these
anachronistic kind of statements they'll
probably get some things wrong um but uh
but i think that particularly from the
from the time period from nuclear
weapons uh till whenever we get our act
together
uh and actually start uh lowering these
risks and putting in place the kind of
institutions and international
cooperation that's needed to keep them
low forever
that this time period that i call the
precipice will be
uh yeah uniquely important
so
what
advice would you give to anyone who's
watching this who
um
is both excited about the long-term
future and
concerned as they should be about the
various existential risks uh facing us
over the next few decades um what can
they do how can they get involved
yeah um i think there's there's various
ways to get involved it's it's tricky at
the moment because we're still at an
early stage of kind of coming to grips
with these things and understanding them
i i think uh reading some some more on
this is a very very smart approach um
and uh i think my book the precipice is
a good place to start
uh also um
uh will mccaskill has a forthcoming book
i think he's just putting the finishing
touches on it now so maybe it's
people have to kind of remember this one
um but he's writing a book on long
termism uh so this general approach that
includes
uh you know to
what can we do now um to improve things
over the long term future and how could
you know we generally get this kind of
integral of benefits over large periods
of time
perhaps there are
avoiding existential risks is one kind
of long-term focused action that could
be very good but maybe there are others
as well such as uh
making discoveries uh or avoiding kind
of smaller forms of lock-in maybe there
are ways that that we get trapped in
these kind of sub-optimal futures that
are very hard to escape from so he's
trying to explore kind of more of that i
think that that would be great um and
uh there's there's a vibrant community
of people uh looking at these things uh
if one searches for long-termism on the
internet you'll probably find some of it
uh and then the effective altruism forum
is a is a place that people discuss a
lot of these things as well
uh and
uh yeah i think that that it could
certainly do with
we'll need many more people uh
interested in these things
right because we always have um you know
well there's very little money compared
to many other issues um
being being spent on these we're
we're also
we've sort of got a the main restriction
is almost brain power right there's just
there's
not that many very very smart people in
the world and a much smaller fraction of
that of those people are actually
working on these particular issues
um in fact some of the very smart ones
are actually working on things that are
accelerating some of these risks yeah um
i mean and so in terms of
uh careers you know a lot a lot of uh
people watching this might be
kind of near the start of their careers
or choosing a area in university uh and
so i think that there's a group called
80 000 hours
being roughly the length of a career but
the idea being you probably should spend
at least a few hours thinking about what
you do with your career if they're going
to be spending 80 000 hours advancing
whatever that was
um
i they've thought a lot about this
question about the brain power type
question you know how could people have
careers that really help with these
things uh so they've got a lot of
information about that which includes
directly working on some of these areas
uh and it also includes uh things like
uh
earning earning money so that you can
give it away in order to help with the
funding of some of these things so
there's lots of different options there
and you know one that i think is kind of
important is
questions about uh government policy and
some of these risks particularly with ai
and that that's something where
often the people in industry just bemoan
the inability of people in the civil
service
to know what what's going on and
regulate it properly
and that's largely because people who
studied computer science don't go into
the civil service um uh you know it's
there's this kind of funny thing where
people who are
in the know bemoan the fact that this
other group of people uh you know
doesn't know enough
but they that they never went there i
mean you know it's one of those things
you know
if you keep choosing to all cluster
together you can't bemoan the fact the
other cluster doesn't have people like
you in it
that's that's actually your fault and
conquer is perhaps your fault more than
their fault um so i think that's
something where
where
we could do a lot more to have um people
with policy
knowledge and interest within uh the
technical communities but also people
with technical knowledge and interest
within the policy communities and kind
of get those those bridges built better
and i think that a lot of what we'll
need to do will ultimately be
international coordination
because these are things that these
existential risks affect the whole world
and so
if something goes wrong just in one
country it could go wrong everywhere
so we'll need a lot of international
coordination to try to sort this out and
we've seen with things like um like
climate change that's very difficult to
do it's possible but difficult within
the current frameworks but maybe we
could we could build better
international institutions for dealing
with this and make improvements of other
sorts so we also need smart people to be
going into that kind of international
relations
um toby this has been absolutely
fascinating thank you so much for your
time um
yeah uh
is there anything else you'd like to add
uh no i think i think we've uh i think
we've covered uh covered almost we've
got a lot of ground yeah yeah yeah
it's uh it's it's been been great to
have the chance to talk to you this
morning
you